[Music]
there are some would make me out to be
the villain
of this here story
[Music]
are you born with destiny
or does it just come
knocking at your door as a young singer
from memphis tennessee
give him a warm hayride welcome
[Music]
mr elvis wrestling
get a haircut buttercup
in that moment
i watched that skinny boy transform
into a superhero
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he was my destiny
wish to promote you mr presley
are you ready to fly i'm ready ready to
fly
tomorrow all america will be talking
about
they might put me in jail for walking
across the street but you're a famous
white boy
the way he's saying is god-given so
there can't be nothing wrong with it
senator kennedy has been shot martin
luther king has been shot to death in
right for memphis tragedy but it has
nothing to do with us it has everything
to do with us
[Music]
when things are too dangerous to say
[Music]
[Music]
and how are you us
[Music]
[Applause]
i just gotta be making the most of this
thing what i can
this could all be over the flash
[Music]
we are the same you and i
we are two odd lonely children reaching
for eternity
[Applause]
the greatest show on earth
elvis has left the building
[Music]
you